let's shift from joe biden and his lies
to other liars that are in this country
rob you wrote a piece for the new york
post on what's going on in minneapolis
and of course ilhan omar is the
wonderful marxist representative
for that area they have a new
anti-police proposal that's going to a
that they'd like to push for that's
going to abolish the police department
and replace it with a new public safety
agency that sounds like it'll work i'm
going to quote you here on november 2nd
residents got get a chance to vote on a
proposed charter amendment that would
abolish the police department and
replace it with a new public safety
agency the initiative aims to remedy
state-sanctioned violence against black
lives in the aftermath of george floyd's
tragic death according to its proponents
the radical activist group yes for
minneapolis the new public safety agency
would strike down the inner strike down
the city the city charters mandate
requiring the police department to
maintain a minimum level of staffing
which is currently deficient by more
than 200 officers
rob come on if we get rid of the police
everything will be fine what are you
talking about why are you trying to
freak people out
yeah yeah exactly i mean you can listen
to elon omar or rather read what she
recently wrote in a in an op-ed saying
that the new the new police system that
they're going to implement is going to
be based in love humanity and compassion
like oh so rosy and nice it just warms
my heart like come on a system based in
love and compassion like that sounds
amazing
the problem is
you have you're reaching record levels
of homicide in minneapolis i've
interviewed some of these people uh you
have communities where there's rampant
violence there's there's gunshots firing
every night um there are people that are
residents leaving in droves you have
kids being diagnosed with psychiatric uh
disorders due to being traumatized from
hearing gunfire every night being afraid
to go play outside walk to the bus stop
etc these residents are overwhelmingly
black low income in neighborhoods uh
where there are a lot of you know kind
of systemic issues that we shouldn't be
paying attention to not you know
abolishing
uh uh the police and and then so that's
the problem with this uh initiative
there are certain parts of it that may
be
that we may look at like having more of
a you know mental health response
certain you know domestic issues and
integrating you know broader mental
health services etc you know that makes
sense but this idea of just this radical
overhaul where we abolish the police and
replace it with this new public safety
agency which you know they say they're
going to use police officers if
necessary if necessary that's absolutely
insane we saw in the aftermath of george
floyd how uh homicides skyrocketed last
year was the second deadliest year
in the city's history because police
officers were treated
like you mentioned in my article i write
about mor the police force being
deficient by more than 200 officers chad
you got to help me with this because you
live in texas and in texas people have
guns and in texas they fund the police
department and people are moving to
texas and texas isn't a bloodbath much
like minneapolis or portland or seattle
et cetera et cetera
is is rav nuts here i mean what's going
why aren't you guys just shooting each
other what's happening i don't get it
you know we're on the heels actually of
a shooting that happened the other day
in mansfield texas
but of course
the judicial system in texas is messed
up too they immediately released the kid
who is on video he's guilty of doing it
down in austin if you call the police
unless you're in the process of being
raped or murdered they've they've
systematically defunded the police in
austin texas they're not going to come
unless you're in one of those dire
situations so it's starting to ebb and
flow over into this state as well
unfortunately and this is the thing that
i was addressing in my new book am i
crazy when i take on this woke culture
you know this is my common sense guide
to the end of the world because as long
as we're embracing this type of mindset
we're only going to see the further
exposure of the depravity of man and
it's going to bleed out into our streets
you know when you start defunding the
police and you start replacing them with
social workers you're going to do
exactly what rob says you're going to
see an increase in violence and crime
and right now people are getting a slap
on the hand you can steal certain things
as long as it doesn't exceed a certain
dollar limit and to me this is almost
like sending a chihuahua into the dog
fight right the chihuahua may have all
the desire to be there may have all of
the fire in his belly
but let's face it we know what the end
result is going to be the chihuahua's
not gonna well no matter how well his
intentions are in being in the pit uh
he's gonna get chewed up and spit out
and that's exactly what we're doing do
you think that any of them at this point
have good intentions
i'm sure that they think they have good
intentions i'm sure that they think that
they are the
whitest white saviors that ever walk the
faith of the earth and that this is
their duty as white progressives and as
activists to make sure that those poor
black people who are being victimized by
criminals in their neighborhood aren't
victimized by police trying to stop
those criminals and i think that's a
real problem as to the social worker
thing there was a little girl who lived
in brooklyn years ago her name was nix
mary brown
she was
attended to by the social workers in new
york there's a lot of funding for social
work in new york they knew about her
they knew her family and they let her
die from neglect she was chained to her
bed her family was very cruel to her and
she died the social workers were on the
case these parents should have been
arrested they should have been locked up
they should have not been allowed to
take care of their child who they
weren't taking care of and you know this
little girl was just one of many these
kinds of problems with social work
groups funded by states and governments
uh it's across the northeast
specifically which is what i know about
it's in new york it's in new jersey it's
in pennsylvania these social workers are
they have a lot of cases uh they show up
they don't really tend to do the job
that's necessary children are still
being neglected and abused and now we're
supposed to add to their workload by
giving them the money that
you know we're currently giving police
then what's going to happen when the
social workers show up and get shot
who's going to do something about it
then